[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the podcast
another edition of roll on roll on life
i guess our ama ask me anything
formatted version of the show where me
and my hype man adam skolnik
journalist activist author co-author of
david goggins can't hurt me
and bon vivant at large joins me
to break down i don't know current
events a little bit
and do things topical answer listener
questions
etc so thanks for tuning in adam how you
doing doing good man
uh um i've been bon viva at home
right like the rest of us you're getting
your swim run workouts in though
i am i've been doing a lot yeah i can
thank you for that i love
this sport it's pretty cool i just got
an email cool did you get the email
it depends how you to find cool did you
get the uh the email from otillo today
that they
they they were going to be hosting their
world championship
event in sweden and now they had to pull
it
oh he's gonna know that it's canceled
for the year yeah
is happening that one is that's this
week yeah but the world championship
event
is getting shelved i'm sorry now at
least so
at the same time we can still get out
and swim run i love it that's it
and what i love about it is it's not
quote unquote cool
i'm the only person that i see yeah
there's nobody else
running around the streets of santa
monica with a pool buoy attached to your
leg in a wetsuit
and and i don't even wear uh goggles
like most
swimmers i wear a mask because i'm so
used to free diving so this low profile
swim
like really a free diving mask do you
get any weird looks
oh yeah you get weird looks in it but
you know i have gotten quicker like it's
interesting when i first started
training for the catalina race
i was like not i i'd been running on a
treadmill
and now and running on the street like i
was not very
quick at all but i have gotten quicker
running longer distances during
quarantine i've definitely gotten more
fit during quarantine it's it's a trip
and
and this last weekend was the first time
i actually
shed the wetsuit and was just in jammers
and a rash guard
yeah and the pool boy and it felt so
much better running in that yeah
right yeah yeah yeah so i remember when
i did the world championship event a
couple years ago
i got together with the local swim run
crew in the days leading up to the race
and we did a workout through the streets
of stockholm
so it was me and like i don't know eight
dudes running
literally down very busy streets on a
weekday
in wet suits with pool buoys and caps on
and the whole thing yeah
and swim run is such a part of the
culture there that no one looked twice
like business people are walking down
the sidewalk and we're
running you know it's such a weird thing
it is weird and then swimming in your
shoes i keep thinking
like who who is watching me get in and
my running shoes swimming but
but i do love it i mean i have to say
like there's something about the workout
that afterwards
like the combination and i've been doing
kind of uh
like a three mile run a 1.1 mile swim
and then like a two to three mile run on
the back end
and it's you know takes me like an hour
and a half and i afterwards i feel
like it's amazing how i feel i feel
better than if i just ran or if i just
swim yeah yeah yeah yeah it's definitely
a full body experience
yeah it's good you're looking fit you
might be the fittest i've ever seen you
thanks man but you have a baby on the
way so things might shift a little bit
the dad bod is real
yeah the fear of the dad bod yeah so
what we do here
is we make a couple announcements we're
gonna talk about a couple top of mind
subjects
um we're gonna share some
good news some show and tell and we're
going to take a quick break and then do
questions from the audience so to kick
things off
i'm excited about this by the way this
new format we're trying to
we're trying to yeah we're trying to
tighten it yeah we'll see how it goes
yes i'm not exactly uh circumspect in in
how i
speak so i don't know how much i can
adhere to the
strictness well you just tell the pine
man to back off
starts if he starts cracking the whip
all right well it's your job to crack
the web
all right um couple quick announcements
up top uh voicing change update this is
my new book
very excited about it we're still in the
process of finalizing it but
most of the heavy lifting is done uh
timeless wisdom inspired from the ritual
podcast it's going to be coming out in
november
it's looking beautiful i'm super proud
of it and excited
about it i'll keep you guys up to date
on exact
release date but i'm so proud of
this creative expression which was very
much a team
effort uh a lot of really talented
designers
and it's been a collaboration with them
and with the guests of course so i'm
excited to be able to
share my guest wisdom in a different
kind of format
so something that's been going on in the
background with everything else that's
been going on i've been working on that
pretty intensely uh also
if you want to have your question
answered here on the podcast you can
leave it
on our facebook group but we would
actually prefer you leave us a voicemail
uh that way we can play the audio on air
which is really fun we're going to do a
little bit of that today
the phone number just so you guys all
have it is 424-235-4626 and i want to
thank everybody who
filled out the survey that we posted on
our facebook group
about this uh subscription idea that
we're working on it was super helpful to
get everybody's input and feedback
we're taking it to heart and that is
also something that is
in motion and i'll keep you posted on
that as well
and then one final quick follow-up thing
oh yeah we waxed on
the other day about queer eye and
caramel
and this is i still can't believe this
happened but
a couple days later i got a dm from
kuramo on instagram and he's like hey
man i love the podcast i'd love to come
on
i was i heard you guys talking about me
which completely blew my mind
has that ever happened before with other
with anybody else that you were kind of
throwing out there on the podcast
has to have happened before maybe i
don't know might be the first time okay
i mean i just couldn't believe that he
yeah i i think he's i think he's bsing
me i don't think he actually
somebody might have told him but uh
whether he listens or not i don't know
we'll ask him but i got him on the
schedule for august so i have that to
look forward to
it's really assuming that that happens
what was really funny about that is that
um my 13 year old daughter who loves
queer eye
she i showed her the dm i was like check
it out i'm going to get karamo to come
to come over uh she's like that's not
him
like that somebody that's a bot account
and i was like no it's got a blue star
blue check she's like somebody hacked
his account like she just couldn't wrap
her head around
the idea that karama would have any
interest whatsoever in anything that i'm
doing
so i think she's not she might actually
shows up and then she'll wonder you know
how much i paid him or something
i guess so we'll see but if you're
listening caramel thank you i'm really
looking forward to talking to you
it's exciting i'm looking forward to it
i'm gonna just come and be in the
audience for that one
because uh i'm excited yeah i can't wait
to
hear him um what are we doing now the
teachable moment so yeah so
uh we're gonna start with some top of
mind subjects and and it starts with a
teachable moment so
uh what do you have for us so one thing
that comes up a lot and i get
a lot of questions around this is how to
set and achieve a goal
so i wanted to just spend a couple
minutes speaking broadly
about my perspective on that i think
it's it's a
it's a nuanced thing like i do think
it's really important to have a goal
but i don't think that it's crucial that
you
obsess about that goal and what i mean
by that is
we have to have something to look
forward to that
that then creates allows you to create
structures that move you in a specific
direction like you can't
you can't score if you don't know where
the goal line is
right so you have to establish what
you're working towards and that brings
everything else into focus
a perfect example of this is i gathered
away most of the quarantine
not working on this book right because
there was no deadline because we're
self-publishing it it just seemed like
this ephemeral thing and i could finish
it whenever i felt like it and what that
meant
is basically i got nothing done on it
for like a year
when we finally established look it's
got to get done by this time
and that time frame seemed almost
impossible to achieve
then i got my butt in gear and i created
a plan and i worked towards it
and accomplished it for me that's what
it took
maybe that's not the way it is for
everybody but i do think that there is
something
magical about setting a date on the
calendar
where you want to have accomplished a
certain thing so not just the goal
of write the book but actually have a
deadline
imposed either right like an extension i
mean the goal in this case
was complete this manuscript by this
date right right so
the deadline the deadline you know
creates structures around
achievement of the goal yeah but then i
kind of forget about
the goal itself and i become very
focused on
the tasks that have to be completed
every single day so i break out
a calendar a big one of those big
desktop calendars
and i try to figure out what has to
happen every single day in order for
this to become
real and then my focus is just on
what needs to happen that day and i
forget about
the big goal and i forget about even
what has to happen tomorrow
then it becomes about process because i
really think that
unless you can fall in love with process
and immerse yourself in process
that the goal doesn't really matter and
i should say also foundational to this
is that whatever goal you set for
yourself
should be the right goal i think just
picking any random goal is not great
like that
goes into a longer conversation about
the inner work required to set the
appropriate goal for yourself
and understanding the why behind it you
need clarity on the why
why is this goal important to you what
is it going to do for your life
once you have that sorted out you set
the goal and then you create
all the tasks that have to happen on the
specific days leading up to that
and you can create little stepping stone
goals along the way that you can
celebrate when you achieve them because
that keeps you
invested it keeps you excited it keeps
you
intrigued by this journey like i think
it's good to reward yourself and take
those moments periodically to celebrate
the small wins because
big goals are achieved by tiny little
wins every single day yeah
so i think that's super important um i
do a terrible job of that i don't really
give myself
space to celebrate anything you should i
know you should
you know i think it feels indulgent to
do that but i think what that does is it
makes me feel more emotionally invested
in the process
and and again it's all i can't emphasize
this enough it is about
process and there's something about once
you've initiated that process
and you're working you're moving forward
and you're
you know you're you're you're you're
you're
you're getting those little wins every
single day that creates
momentum and there's something really
magical about momentum
i just know for me personally when i
have momentum
then i become this this moving object
that's very difficult to stop
and i don't know what it is about that
psychologically or neurochemically
but for me it works once i've
established momentum
then other things feel like a
distraction and i'm much more invested
in the process itself i would say in
addition to that
that it's important to create
accountability for yourself you can be
accountable to yourself but i think it's
also
important to be accountable to
externalities other people
who will help keep you on track i think
you need to be selective about who those
people are you want people who
are are on your page and are going to
celebrate
you and are are also you know um
encouraging you towards the achievement
of this goal
you don't wanna you don't wanna be
accountable to people who don't believe
in you or think that you're wasting your
time so
who you pick to be your accountability
partner i think is really important
that person should also be somebody
who's not afraid to call you out when
you're
missing the mark you know this is
something that you see all the time with
fitness goals you do it with somebody
else or with a small team or a group of
people
you're more likely to get up at five
o'clock in the morning and show up for
that
group run or that november project
workout because you know
your friends are there waiting for you
and they're gonna notice if you don't
show up
so it's the positive accountability the
people who are to say keep going you're
doing great and the negative
accountability of people who are going
to hold you to account if you don't
show up or you start to slack
yeah and there's something specifically
about writing books
too that the process kind of takes over
your brain in a weird way i mean it's
so all-encompassing yeah it's like it's
like a tunnel that you can't get out of
and the momentum becomes just charging
through it
and it can become distracting you can
get like lost in the tunnel
but for me when i'm working on something
then
at any time of day ideas can pop in to
improve whatever that
piece of writing is that i'm working on
especially if it's a book but then those
breaks whether it's going out for a swim
run workout or taking a walk or whatever
it is are important to then
gain perspective right that's where the
idea pops in or the thing you didn't
think of when you're so mired in the
details
you know you have to provide space for
that the problem solving yeah
yeah and then if you miss like a daily
goal accountability wise
um but you still have the bigger goal on
the calendar do you have advice not to
get too down on yourself or or how do
you
like if you if you start to fall off
yeah if you start to fall off how do you
refocus
well i think you then recalibrate you
break out the calendar and figure out
all right so i'm behind what's going to
have to happen for me to
achieve this by this date you either
change the date or you create a
different
structure to which you're more likely to
adhere
i think you have to do an inventory and
say why is it that i fell off or
couldn't
maintain this you know daily routine
maybe i was
uh you know over overly
um optimistic about what i could achieve
in a certain day like
make sure that whatever you establish as
your daily practice
is manageable and fits within the
construct of your busy life
yeah if you if you you if you you know
over cast that then you're setting
yourself up for failure so i think it's
important that
the things you have to do on a daily
basis um are very manageable because the
truth is
in order to achieve big goals you don't
have to do that much
in a single day as long as you're doing
it consistently and it's the one percent
rule like there's a compound interest
that occurs like if you're showing up
for a half an hour every day to do
something if you do that
every day for a year or 18 months or two
years or 10 years
the difference is astronomical it's not
just an additive
thing it's it's it's it's an exponential
benefit that you reap from doing that so
again it's all back to
the now the day and it's related to
principles of 12-step which is
you know it's just about what you have
it's just about the moment like what are
you doing
today like in sobriety it's like make
sure your head hits the pillow
sober that's all you got to worry about
you don't have to worry about tomorrow
with respect to achieving a goal it's
like okay here's here are the things i
have to do today and i don't have to
worry about
the things i have to do tomorrow or that
big intimidating goal that's looming out
in the surface that just seems
impossible
and there's a liberation that comes from
like
all of a sudden once you have it mapped
out and you know it's about the little
bricks to build the big
structure um there's a lib you know
when you're just sitting there looking
at the big structure this big design
that you have in your brain and and
you're like wow how am i going to ever
do that
and you just focused on that it does
become intimidating but once you
start playing one brick yeah you can
become paralyzed but once you lay one
brick
you realize wait a second i can do this
you know just
everything becomes manageable yeah and
every brick that you lay
creates additional confidence yeah in
your ability to achieve the thing that
feels impossible and a perfect example
of that
was me training for ultraman like
you know i wasn't you know contrary to
what people might suspect or imagine
like i wasn't some crazy gifted
you know endurance athlete like i worked
really hard to achieve
my ultra endurance goals and when i
began
training for this race that just seemed
like an absolute impossibility
it was hard for me to wrap my brain
around the idea that one day i would get
to a place where
on the third day of this ultra endurance
double iron man race that i'd be able to
run
52 miles and it was just brick by brick
by brick
over an extended period of time you know
leading up to
doing a 40-mile training run which was
like the craziest thing i could ever
imagine doing
six months earlier that would have
seemed impossible and it's literally
just by doing
little things every single day that are
moving you forward
beautiful i love it so um let's uh
there's a couple things we want to talk
about from the news first is
uh congressman john lewis's passing
just give a little bit of a recap
john lewis was the child of a
sharecropper
ended up going to nashville for college
uh
where he got involved in desegregation
of lunch counters
and that nashville crew ended up being
really foundational informative of this
of the student movement within the civil
rights movement
he became a freedom rider one of the
original 13 freedom riders
that rode greyhound buses to the south
to desegregate
the national transportation system
he ended up the head of the student
nonviolent coordinating commit
non-violent coordinating committee which
is basically the student arm
affiliated with martin luther king's uh
southern leadership
southern christian leadership conference
which was his organization
um he was the youngest speaker march on
washington he led the selma march
um he got beat and uh he's been arrested
like 40 times yeah something like that
and uh a congressman for over 30 years i
mean the man was a giant
yeah he was a giant he's widely
considered the
he was the conscience of congress and
what a beautiful expression of life like
somebody
when i think about him i think about
somebody who
lived their life in strict accordance
with their values
and and never really wavered even when
you know basically culture and society
was
up against him like he was he had the
fortitude
and the sense of self to
never you know basically allow himself
to be
swayed from what he believed in and that
strength that center of gravity that he
was able to hold for so many years
is so powerful and why he's so revered
you know he will certainly be missed and
it's interesting that you know he's
lived most incarnations of the civil
rights movement i mean instrumental in
the civil rights act getting passed
all the way up through the recent
protests at the very end of his life
he let us sit in in 2016 in in congress
florida house of representatives to try
to force
um the republicans to move on gun
control issues
yeah um yeah so he was protesting all
the way through
yeah i i uh you know i aspire
to that level of advocacy and strength
yeah
grayson schaefer who i know from my
outside magazine
um he used to be an editor there he
posted something on
instagram just thinking about the amount
of courage it takes to march
into the teeth of an attack uh of
you know it was it was vigilantes and
cops on the bridge in selma the edmund
pettus bridge
and to lead that group going in there
unarmed
ready to get beat uh knowing you could
die
knowing yeah knowing that you know is a
very perilous situation
and hit and always you know his his
whole thing was non-violence
from the beginning yeah and learning
those gandhian techniques
yeah and to understand that like i take
away from like reading about him
recently it's just like
like the incubator that was nashville
you don't think of nashville as an
incubator for the civil rights movement
right now but
it really was because it wasn't just um
john lewis other people came out of that
and and kind of the the entire student
arm of the civil rights movement came
out of the the people that were working
together in nashville yeah
um pretty interesting yeah he was
beloved
on both sides of the aisle he was and he
will be
missed obama wrote a beautiful piece
about him on medium and also the new
york times
wrote an extended obit that is worth
your attention and i can link those up
in the show notes
cool um so then obviously the big issue
here
uh this last couple weeks has been the
reemergence of
a virulent covid19 in the united states
of america and all that that has wrought
and i think that we're both we don't
want to get too politicized here with it
but a couple things have come out stand
out for me
and one that i wanted to talk to you
about and get your take on was
this this idea of of masks or
anti-authoritarianism and and the
american love of freedom
and how that's being reflected right now
into two
very different takes on things one is
the anti-mask
crowd who people who don't want to wear
masks see that see the
the orders of mask ordinances around
cities and states as an example of
authoritarianism
and then in portland right now there are
extended black lives matter protests
and in and the city
uh has been dealing with that for ever
since george floyd died
and more recently um the federal
government has sent in
uh customs and border patrol agents that
are
basically jack boots on the ground that
are taking people off the street even
people who aren't at the protests have
claimed to be arrested
and in black blacked out cars by
unidentified
federal agents and then turned up the
next thing you know they're in federal
court
so in a way that feels very
authoritarianist
to a lot of people especially those
protesters
and and you have kind of those two
things juxtaposed and on the mask front
um i was reading a great article in the
salt lake tribune
by courtney tanner and it was about how
in the conservative counties they don't
want their children to have to wear
masks
mothers are spitting in masks uh at
county council meetings
um and then you go to huntington beach
california where the guys chad and jt
yeah who what's their youtube channel
those guys chad goes deep
right and and they have amazing they
they these guys are hilarious and they
turn up at like city council meetings
all the time and troll the
video they're going around trying to
give away free mass they're trying to
give away
super angry at them exactly and it's the
same thing that's happening in provo
utah
so it's not just happening it's not
fringe really these
reactions to masks it's so interesting i
think
you know what i find fascinating about
this is the different lenses through
which people
perceive authoritarianism
on the one hand you have the anti-mass
crowd
who are who are you know rallying
against
this edict that we wear masks as an
infringement on their liberties
and on the other hand we have these
federal
troops essentially this militarized
police force that's patrolling the
streets of portland
in uniforms that don't have names and
don't necessarily
designate their authority and you know
unmarked vehicles and vans etc
rounding people up arresting people uh
and and there's a certain contingent of
people who
you know i would i would suspect that
the people who are
against wearing masks don't have such a
big problem with that
and and the question then becomes vice
versa yeah and vice versa right so
yeah the people exactly so the question
then becomes
what is truly authoritarian what is the
real risk here
where are we seeing inroads on our on
our democratic ideals
and living in a truly lib you know
liberty
oriented democratic society
right to me you know and i have to like
is this my cognitive bias like to me
you know i don't have a problem wearing
a mask it's a mild and i don't like
wearing a mask it's a mild inconvenience
but to the extent that there is any
evidence whatsoever that it might be
helpful or protective for other people
to
you know keep them from getting sick i'm
happy to do it
i'm happy to do it but when i see
troops in a city on federal authority
against the wishes of certain state
governors and mayors and and local
politicians
patrolling streets and arresting people
seemingly you know i i don't know i'm
not i'm i haven't born witness to any of
this but i read that esquire article
about this
that's more deeply concerning to me and
it feels like
a greater threat to our liberty and and
far more authoritarian than this idea
like hey let's wear masks and look out
for each other
yeah um i i talked to somebody who was
at the protest in
portland on friday night and uh
and there it was similar to what we had
here where
the police kind of did escalate the
tension as opposed to try to de-escalate
it um
but they ask them who they are will they
identify themselves
i think that that has started to trickle
out it's really hard to know exactly
what's happening because
when you come when you have these kinds
of really tense
situations nobody is uh objective
observer
you know so it's hard to know exactly
what's happening and what is mistake
mistakes being made that are legitimate
infringements on civil liberty and what
is like
they're doing it on purpose like you
know where where is that line it's so
gray
but we do know the mayor of portland has
asked for
the uh troops the the the federal agents
to leave
um we do know that um and
you know there was this line from the
salt lake coverage
or this was in provo and one of the
leaders a republican who
sits on the county council in provo said
i don't like government mandates and
he's
he's on the county he's on the county
council he's i don't like government
mandates but and that's true right like
so
a lot of us don't like it so the
question is like what is it in the
american soul
that makes us these love this lover of
liberty but maybe to our own detriment
to the point that we we want we don't
want to be told what to do no matter
what
but in this case in terms of the masks
people are doing it and it could really
come back at them in in the form of a
virus that could kill them
like what is that and it's already kind
of made us
uh nationality non-grotta all over the
world we're down to about 28 countries
we can go visa free
it used to be we can go almost anywhere
where the american passport that
passport has been devalued
right so there's a there's a stricture
on our liberty right there our inability
to
to travel globally yeah it's so
fascinating
how vociferous and angry people are
certain people are
when asked to wear a mask and you see
that in that comedic video with those
guys they're basically like hey do you
want a free mask and people are flipping
them a bird and
the [ __ ] off yes and getting really
angry it's not a mask it's a muzzle so
why is it
why is it making people so angry
i think is one question like what what
is that rage all about and that's
something we talked about
a couple weeks ago right that like
repressed rage that's just beneath the
surface that
i think has a lot to do with you know
people feeling like they don't have
as much agency in their lives as as they
feel like they deserve
and that's a longer thing that we went
into before but
juxtaposing that onto what we're seeing
in portland
and then contextualizing it with this
this argument around free speech like
where
where is the speech being impinged like
if you're unable to protest because
you're going to get arrested even if
you're doing it legally
that seems like a greater repercussion
and inroad on free speech than being
told to wear a mask
well they they relate right why is and
and how and why did wearing a mask
become so
politicized well that i think takes us
back to
the q anon and all that all the youtube
coverage and
and the negativity around this the
people who think the pandemic is a hoax
which you did hear in that
and that's that comedic video in
huntington beach but you also hear it
in the in the council rooms and in the
protest lines in salt lake city and
provo
that people don't believe it's uh
they don't believe in the virus like
there's a lack
so there's this idea that we we want
freedom to the point of our own
detriment right
there's something about that's very
american about that that we want freedom
so badly it's to our own detriment and
you know our friend dan buettner studied
this when he did blue zones of happiness
like where
where is where does the paradox of
choice kind of tip
against you when you have so much
individual freedom that
it actually works to uh
to reduce your happiness so the example
that dan
cites is singapore right which is
basically an authoritarian
rule yeah where
yeah basically where for certain
seemingly
uh minor offenses you can get caned and
to you know the repercussions are very
severe yes and yet
the happiness quotient there seems to be
very high yeah
because it's just super interesting some
of that's basic needs are taken care of
versus freedom so here we we lust after
freedom
but we don't do a great job of taking
care of people's basic needs
uh you know we we don't have the
education system is as has suffered
uh we could go all the way through the
list um
you know so it's interesting it's just
something to think about like like with
with the on an individual level what do
you think about that like
for you you kind of create your own
discipline around
sobriety around um being plant-based all
of those things
and and you could look at that as i'm
not allowing myself this or that but
what has come
with is there a freedom in that or is
there a freedom within a structure that
we should be aspiring to instead
of all freedoms all the time yeah i
think i think that's a really good
question
um i think that that that
if you look at any creative expression
some of the some of the most
beautiful works of art come out of
restriction right like the independent
movie where they had no money
and no time and yet created this amazing
work of art that stands the test of time
had they had 100 million dollars to do
it and as much time as they wanted
that doesn't necessarily mean that it
would be of more value
or even better right you hear this time
and time again with artists like
because there were restrictions placed
upon them
that forced a level of creativity that
they were forced to tap into something
that they didn't know that they had
right and that brought
greater expression to whatever it is
that they were trying to say
you know you could say the same thing
like to
my own personal experience okay i know
drugs and alcohol i only eat plant-based
foods
i've you know i've removed a lot of
things from my life
so i have restricted choice in certain
regards
doesn't that mean that i'm less happy or
that i don't enjoy my life and my answer
is that
that it's quite the contrary through
that restriction
i have created greater freedoms for
myself
and there's no better parallel to what's
happening because if if we all wear
masks and we can get a handle on this
virus we can actually have our lives
back right
and i think another thing less
restriction another thing worth noting
that that that our mutual friend
dave goggins would probably echo is that
we need to develop a greater capacity
for anti-fragility
yes we need to be more emotionally
resilient to everything that's going on
yes and that comes through putting
yourself through
difficult situations personally where
you become
adapted to being outside of your comfort
zone
extrapolating that it means that when
you are in the presence of somebody who
doesn't agree with you
or perhaps you're anti-mask but somebody
wants to give you a free mask
you don't lose your [ __ ] you need to
like fit
and you can maintain some level of
equanimity and grace
and kindness with other people but the
fact that
everybody is so hair triggered by
everything
when i see that i see a lack of
emotional
agility i see it i see a very
emotionally fragile populace that could
benefit
from maybe focusing more on their own
personal challenges and trying to become
a better version
of who they are rather than shouting at
other people
who are voicing some opinion right that
perhaps they don't include
you you guys have to see the chat and jt
thing shout out to chad and jt
we'll put uh we'll put a link up here
yes i think casey tweeted that one out
too oh did he
yeah i um my thing with mass my hair
trigger is
the people that wear the mask but with
their nose peeking out right
which is basically like would you walk
down the street with your dick hanging
out well there's that meme everywhere
yeah like it's the same as doing that
exactly
i know i see that all the time like why
wear pants
i trust the guy like i remember being in
paris and seeing a guy like just a naked
guy walking down the street
and he's less creepy than someone who's
like half dressed
i also told chris health in one of our
coaches corner episodes
that we did one at the very beginning of
the pandemic we were talking about masks
and i i said the masks
the masks suffer from a branding problem
if we just
called them uh you know aerobic capacity
enhancers or something like
because all the arguments around like
you're breathing your own
you're breathing carbon dioxide you're
not this is making you more sick or
it's impairing your immune system like
the science doesn't bear that out it's
not true but
to the extent that you may believe that
it's
inhibiting your oxygen intake this is
just making you a stronger human being
your body is there you go
adapting to less oxygen which is making
you
a better athlete over time so if you
just if
we just rebranded or renamed these
things as
as athletic enhancers cardiovascular
yeah basically yeah maybe maybe they
they would have a higher
adoption rate i don't think so i think
that uh there's some web
there's some youtube video out there
that we're not watching
probably that's not part of my algorithm
of suggested videos
no the evils of masks but um but you
know listen
i think uh for me as a long time travel
writer where i i had this many times
with the american passport like where i
could just breeze through without a visa
to so many countries
and to see that kind of flake away is
sad to me but i do understand it and i
kind of felt like at some point that
could come that could happen and um to
me that's sad like
it's it's it shows at one time it was
the passport that can get you almost
anywhere without having to go through
the process of getting a visa
and now most of the places we can go
without a visa are
in the caribbean the bahamas just banned
us um
we're banned from europe i mean it's
it's unprecedented yeah it hasn't
happened before
yeah yeah well the incidence rates are
you know through the roof right now
florida arizona california
you know we've got real problems trying
to contain this thing and
to the extent that wearing a mask might
help
i'm gonna wear a mask all right cool
let's go into something
another segment we're calling it
show-and-tell
and uh where we get to talk about things
that we wash
we saw we're gonna you know it could be
food it could be media
well let's start i want to start with
tommy riv oh right we should start with
while we're on the subject of mass so
tommy rizz um tommy rivers poozi for
those of you don't know
uh is a legendary beast of all things
running endurance and ultra endurance
he's a beautiful guy
and a very accomplished runner i think i
think his pr in the marathon is
something like 218 he's won
two i believe two consecutive rock and
roll marathons
beloved in the endurance community a
legend on the trails and the road
and uh a guy that i met when
i flew out to utah to run the final
marathon with the iron cowboy for his 50
iron mans in 50 states in 50 days and
and tommy had spent
quite a bit of time with the iron cowboy
i don't know how many days
of that adventure he he he joined
james lawrence but it was a lot and so i
got to run with him and
talk to him and spend a little time with
him just a beautiful
guy loving guy smart guy he's got two
daughters and a wife
um i think he's getting his phd i know
he's a um
he's a a physical therapist but i think
he was in grad school i don't know if he
completed grad school or not but anyway
the reason i bring him up is because uh
he is in the icu right now i think he's
been in the icu for over three weeks
coming up on a month
with like symptoms i'm not sure that
he's been technically diagnosed with
covid
how old you but he's got maybe
early 40s okay i think he has severe
respiratory distress and he's in very
serious condition right now
and he's been posting videos on
instagram uh
sharing you know what it's like to be in
his condition and this is
this is one of the fittest human beings
you're ever going to see i mean you said
218 marathon specimen of you know just
this the eight pack
abs and just live and be you know with
the beautiful stride and just
a magnificent beautiful athlete and and
like i said a very loving guy and he's
very sick right now
so there's a gofundme um that's been set
up to
allow people to help contribute to his
significant
medical expenses and i just wanted to
wish him well and
alert people to the gofundme this is a
guy who's given so much to the community
and really needs our help right now so
i'm going to link up
that uh that gofundme in the show notes
and you can find him on instagram
at tommy underscore rivs so
we're thinking about you tommy and his
brother uh jacob as well
who's been trying to help get the word
out about this we're with you man
just goes to show you and he'll and
tommy's like wear a mask
you know yeah well yeah i mean
there is look people with metabolic
disease
people are overweight people with
cardiovascular and respiratory ailments
are more
susceptible to covid than
than more seriously serious right right
excuse me
and like i said tommy is not officially
coronavirus diagnosed
um it's it's weird that they can't
figure out what this is but to the
extent that perhaps this is kovid
um this is a guy who you would think is
very unlikely to
be suffering to this extent from
something like this so
just be aware get well tommy
um switching gears switching gears uh
thanks for that sorry about that my
computer
has died so i need to power it up
um but let's get to uh darren olean's
new show with zach
down to earth so most people i've
probably been made aware of this by now
but
my man darren olean who's been on the
podcast a bunch of times
um has a new show with zac efron on
netflix it's called down to earth
it's a limited series i think it's six
episodes
where these two guys traveled a really
cool
destination iceland and explore
um everything from regenerative
agriculture
to sustainable energy and everything in
between
and this is really cool it was the
number one
show on netflix a couple days ago i
don't know where it is right now it's
certainly in the top five or ten at the
moment um
and it's been great to see darren
get introduced to a much more mainstream
broad audience
than he was originally and this is a guy
who deserves a spotlight as much as
anything he is
not only one of my best friends but he's
a wealth of knowledge on
so many subjects and this is now an
opportunity for everybody
in the world to experience some level of
of his of his expertise and i think it's
great
and to pair it with zach is you know
this is a guy who can
you know he's so world famous that that
you know people are going to tune in
just for him and then they get
to see darren and i just think it's
really cool so i'm really proud of them
and there's a there's a
kind of interesting backstory to this
which is
that zach got introduced to darren
because he heard darren on the podcast
right so that's what got him interested
in darren to begin with which is super
cool so i feel like
that's awesome like i you know i helped
you know
behind the scenes i helped you guys get
together
um in fact i was out cycling a couple
years ago
with um my friend conor dwyer who's been
on the show before
who's really close with zach and with
dylan ephron
um zach's brother who i'm friends with
and
and they were going on and on about
darren i was like well let's
when we finish the ride let's go over
we'll go over to his house so i brought
these guys over to darren's house
they met him and they're like oh zach
zack's going to be so mad that he wasn't
here and darren's
taking them through all his super foods
and his special water stuff
and you know everything like that and
that led to
those guys getting together and
ultimately creating the show so
i'm going to take full credit
without you but i'm just really i'm
really excited about it i think
it's a perfect blend of kind of
entertainment and education it's
certainly
oriented around a mainstream audience i
think if you were to ask darren he would
have preferred that it was
it struck a much more serious in-depth
tone but
you know in order for shows like this to
kind of cross-pollinate and reach the
most number of people they also have to
be
kind of light and entertaining as well
so well i think
i would like to ask darren because i for
someone who has brought
a i mean i'm 95 plant-based occasionally
i eat a little bit of fish but less and
less so now
but i've brought my wife who is
plant-based april to mongolia for a
month and you know argentina
and iceland look to be in that same
score like it's not easy to be
plant-based in some of these locations i
would love to hear
if when you i think you're gonna have
the guys on right it'd be good to have
well here in the answer to that no i'll
have darren back on
um zach has left the country okay i
don't know that i'm
i'm i'm it i i can say where he is i
know where he is
because i i wanted to get those those
guys on together
um i'll get dara back on to talk more in
depth about it that'd be an interesting
thing sure there's all kinds of cool
behind-the-scenes stories yeah for sure
yeah that'd be cool um
awesome and then uh another documentary
uh but not a series but a an actual uh
feature-length dock
was finally released and and that was
fabulous i know you're excited about
this did you watch it
i did watch it yeah we are freestyle
love supreme yes
what a great movie it's an amazing movie
do you want to tell people uh
yeah the basics so if you caught my
episode a couple days ago with dr andrew
huberman i had
for the audio version of the podcast i
had utkarsh ombudkar on
for a brief like 15-20 minute segment to
talk about
the movie ukarsh's longtime friend of
mine
um who has been on the podcast he was on
two years ago
i think it's episode 373 if i'm not
mistaken how did you meet him
um i just i know him through friends of
friends and
he's friends with dk too uh and
what i love about utkarsh is just this
amazing i mean i love a lot of things
about him but
but his story is remarkable in this
incredible arc that he's had from being
somebody who
was very talented as a young person but
also very much in his ego
and and and lost in his addiction
um that it it it it really hamstrung
his ability to move forward in his
career and it wasn't until he got sober
that he's had this beautiful renaissance
where now his career is exploding
but one of the part of his origin story
is being part of this small group
of very talented artists called
freestyle love supreme
of which lin-manuel miranda was a
founding member of
which was this which is essentially this
group of people who would get together
and do these freestyle spoken word
spontaneous performances that were very
audience
engaged
yeah yeah yeah and and this is the kind
of
creative crucible that birthed
everything from in the heights to
hamilton like hamilton doesn't exist
without
freestyle love supreme probably all goes
back to that and this documentary
is a elegant and lovely
portrait of not just
that story but the love and friendship
between
these young men and they have incredible
footage of them when they're all super
young
yeah because it's like it started
between anthony and
tommy tommy yeah anthony tommy and
wesleyan and was
uh did lynne go to wesley lynn went to
work yeah
so four guys from wesleyan basically
that became friends but two of them were
really tight and they were the
they were freestyling together and then
lynne joined the group
and it was like you know it's just like
a supernova
yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh and they
you so you see these guys from the early
20s
and you follow them to the edinburgh uh
you know
theater festival yeah the fringe
festival uh
you follow them back to new york they're
like they get the keys to
um a book shop that that uh became their
their house theater
a little black box theater um and like
30 seats
you like 30 seats and then you see you
know lin's arc and you see how some
people
kind of i think um utkarsh came came
in a couple years later later yeah but
when he came in he was like
like lynn called them nuts and bolts the
best pure rapper they had
i know it was crazy lynn basically is
like he's the most verbally dexterous
rapper i've ever seen yeah and but then
they trained him to like
to steer it towards improv comedy and
make light-hearted stuff versus kind of
the big up yourself
type rap battle where that kind of
tradition that he came from
and um it's so interesting to see the
footage the footage itself is
worth watching so you could see this and
then of course like you said
you learn um tommy's secret to becoming
a tony trone-winning director
latching yourself on to a macarthur
genius just
just follow lin-manuel wherever he goes
but the movie is very clear that tommy
elevates everything that they do like
was you know sure to point out that you
know
tommy was the guy who could call him on
his bs or tell him when he was
missing the mark a little bit and you
know the fact that those guys have
stayed together
through thick and thin and and growing
older and all the kind of permutations
of life
and always come back to this one thing
like the reverence that they have
for this creative this very pure
creative expression the recognition
that not only do they owe it to that
for all the success they've had in their
life that it's critical in keeping them
fresh and creatively
creatively you know inspired and
active you know and i think the lessons
in there
are are you know respecting the process
like
i think if there's anything and utkarsh
pointed this out when i talked to him
the other day like
the movie doesn't exactly demonstrate
how long all of this took
right like this is going on for many
many years you know before
hamilton and then freestyle of supreme
being on broadway and remind me to tell
you the experience of seeing it in
person
yeah but just the idea
that it's friendship it's it's
pure love and devotion to a very
particular art form
that forces you in a way that other art
forms perhaps
don't do as stridently to be completely
present
and to be in the purest expression
of your personal truth in the moment too
right in the moment i love i love when
lynn has to puke
like before the show like even every
time now
like even now yeah and um i mean i think
that's amazing and like talking about
tommy
he's he's like one of those that knows
how to coach the greats you know that's
what they say about
great directors they know how to coach
the best actors and the best
the best creatives so yeah i think that
that's not an easy skill to have i mean
that's
right that's amazing and chris jackson
who is george washington
in hamilton mm-hmm um he was in this
group from the beginning he was
in the heights so it's it does show you
like the last if you can form a band of
creative
souls like that you can stick together
uh it's incredible
where that can take you yeah um and you
saw them
i did how did you so you said i remember
you going it was like last fall right
it was in november i was in new york and
i was there to do some i can't remember
why i was there do some podcasts and
stuff like that but i was like i'm
seeing this show
yeah oh karsh is like i got you covered
i got an extra ticket for bird our
our our book agent i brought him and i
had a sense of what it was gonna be
but i was not prepared for just how
transcendent
this experience was like it was
magnificent i mean bird was just like
the entire time i've never been more
entertained in a theatrical production
in my life
like amazing i just was astounded
at the skill of these
individuals to do what they do because
it's so inaccessible like
the quickness of their mind and their
ability to rapidly respond to what's
happening and
create something so extraordinary out of
whole cloth in the moment
is this very difficult for me to wrap my
head around so it was incredible
to witness it how long did it go i mean
i can't remember it's like an hour and a
half and it's very audience
participatory i mean you see
in the in the documentary they bring
somebody up on the stage and they
they ask them about their day and then
they just create an entire musical
number out of this
person's mundane daily experience and
it's the most hilarious thing you've
ever seen
um and then afterwards we went
backstage bird and i went backstage and
then we're standing
on the stage after everyone left and
it's like uh carson me
and those other guys and like lin's
standing right there and i was like
i'm looking at bird like making i was
like how is this happening like how am i
standing on a broadway stage
next to lin-manuel miranda with my buddy
ukarsh like
and i think about karsh's arc and how it
all could have gone terribly wrong
and how he he pulled his life together
and is now able to be in his full
expression
doing what he loves and on a broadway
state
like it's just it it gives me goosebumps
to think about it and
and it reminds me of
human potential you know when we can
become spiritually fit
what we're capable of doing and it's
never too late to actually
find that redemption right like if you
can dedicate yourself back to the cause
and to yourself and to be
kind of connected to your self in a
new way an empowered way i don't
understand one thing i forgot to mention
when i had ukraine the other day
is is he's the guy like if you missed my
podcast and you don't know who this
person is
if you watch the oscars you will
remember he was the guy on stage who did
a freestyle rap like in the middle of
the show
where he was talking about people in the
audience and
go back and watch that it's pretty
incredible i think i do remember
remember that i do remember
that was karsh okay i do remember that
for that yes
amazing i mean uh
it did if you're and if you're a fan of
hamilton it's must-see
obviously yeah 100 100 um
here's our big show and tell me so we
have a big show
there is a new plant-based product
dropping right now it's a collab between
kfc
a kfc beyond meat collab uh-huh
it's called beyond fried chicken we have
it
and here it is blake there it's it's
available in
how many like 59 restaurants in southern
california
um not every kfc there was one in simi
valley
though yeah it's interesting the ones
that they chose it's like it's not the
ones you
think are in the communities that you
would associate with like plant-based
venice and los felis no it's like in
kind of the areas where there there
there aren't so many options which i
think is great i think that is good i
wonder if that was part of the calculus
thing
how they made those decisions about
where to where to you know
they didn't tell me that um they did
share you know one of them is in
redlands which is near loma linda which
is a blue zone kind of very much a
vegetarian place and there's other
vegetarian fast food places in loma
linda yeah
um but they said it was a wheat and soy
protein so not the pea protein
that you get beyond beyond burger patty
the burger is is a pea protein base so
this is wheat and soy this is wheat and
soy i'm not sure they didn't
they didn't kind of divulge if it's
using the same cow gut machines
that from the but i'm guessing not i'm
guessing it's totally different i know
that
it started in 2019 when kfc
um and beyond got together and i think
it was kfc approached them but
um at least that's what the press agent
said to me beyond meat is also available
at carl's jr i believe as a burger as a
burger
yeah and impossible is the fat burger
place right another place
yeah yeah yeah that's right yeah i know
like burgers
burger king is impossible yeah yeah
right carl's jr is beyond i think
yes yeah yeah yeah so we picked this up
and the idea was we were going to do a
taste test i've never tried this but
then
adam informed me that it is being
handled by the same uh
people that handle the chicken and fried
in the same fryers which is
uh obviously that's not surprising
that's not ideal so
that's ideal as a as a machine as a
vegan i'm gonna
i'm gonna forego but firmness for that
runner like myself that's not looking
like adam is going to try
they look like chicken mcnuggets they do
they they are
they don't look like a chicken
does not look like a chick it looks like
a
it's a rhombus yeah oh i can smell it
though
it's probably cold at the smell those i
mean you can taste the herbs and spices
yeah kernels herbs and spices
it's good it has more of you know a lot
of times
the plant-based chicken products are
very rubbery
yeah this one has more give to the tooth
it does it does have
more of a chicken breast kind of uh
texture yeah chewiness mm-hmm striated
dk you should try one of these yeah
blake and deacon
yeah come on in here i'm surprised you
got it
on camera why because you guys are i'm
gonna share
my i'm gonna share my opinions on this
in a second yeah all right give it a go
tell me what you think you don't want
one
it does feel like kentucky fried chicken
on the outside yeah yeah
yeah i don't have uh it smells like
kentucky fried chicken i can tell you
that
my palate isn't as developed as adam
but i would eat this yeah
all right especially knowing that it's
healthy
it even looks like chicken so here's the
thing
let's break it down you're approving
look i also love impossible burgers but
i don't think it's the healthiest way to
approach your diet right so here's
here's the thing
this is somewhat controversial so i want
to kind of be very clear about my
perspective and my opinion on this i
think
the fact that there's this collab
between kfc
and beyond is a good thing just like i
support beyond meets collaboration with
carl's jr and impossible's collaboration
with burger king like these are
improvements iterations on a broken
system
now these are not health foods even if
this
was not fried in the same deep fryer
where they
cook chicken um i might have tasted it
but this is not something i'm gonna be
eating maybe
as a delicacy like once in a very rare
blue moon
but um that's why people go to kfc for
the delicacies yeah
you're not going to kfc or carl's jr or
burger king to eat healthy right they
call it the cavities
food these are not health foods no at
the same time
i think it's a good thing that this is
happening i think that
this is a move it's a pivot away from
animal agriculture
it's a pivot towards a more plant-based
world certainly
animals lives are going to be spared as
a result of this
and this is a good thing to the extent
that we can introduce
plant analogs to animal foods that
people like
and convince them that it tastes just as
good and is slightly
healthier than what they were eating
before is a move in the right direction
and that's a move that i celebrate there
are a lot of hardcore vegans who would
say
you know you got a boycott burger king
you got a boycott mcdonald's and all
these places they're slaughtering
billions of animals every year that's
all
true but we have to celebrate the winds
and we live in a capitalist society
these
gigantic conglomerates are responding to
consumer demand
and to the extent that the consumers are
demanding plant-based foods or
plant-based analogs to
animal foods that they like that's
something we need to
support right we need to fan the flames
of positive change
and if everybody starts buying the
beyond version
of these chicken mcnuggets at kfc
they're going to make more of those
and less chickens kfc burger king
mcdonald's carl's
these these are companies that are not
going away no right
they're trying to adapt to the times
they're not
doing this because they're trying to be
amazing human beings they're responding
to consumer demand
they want money yeah basically it's a
capitalist pivot
because this is where consumer demand is
going and the more consumers that demand
plant-based foods the more companies
like this are going to react and respond
and
move in a direction that is better for
everybody
yeah i mean for me i've come to
embracing a plant-based
almost exclusively i should say
plant-based lifestyle
because of the cruelty
of the system and because of the water
pollution
and the runoff that comes from it and
destroys oceans so
i'm systeming animal agriculture um
so you know that's where i come from but
i also have always liked fried chicken
and there's things i do like
about that kind of old diet that i used
to have and so it's nice
for me i like having this option um one
thing that troubles me a little bit from
all these kind because they're they're
like tech companies beyond and
impossible and i love i
i do like them and i buy their products
and so i'm and i should say in full
disclosure that i own a couple shares of
beyond
not that that's influencing none of that
right now but
just in full transparency i like that um
i don't but um but i i would i would
but um i don't yet but the one thing
that kind of is curious is
is as as bad as the current kind of cafo
structure and these
like the high density raising of animals
is
um you know it didn't start that way
and it used to be um food could be one
of those things that you could empower
smaller businesses and a family farm and
it's obviously not that way anymore
certainly not with chicken farming
not with chicken farming so i'm not
saying that this is like going to change
but there is
something troubling about like the
winner take all thing that happens from
from when businesses when the siphon of
money starts going to fewer and fewer
straws
right and and it kind of goes up and
enriches less
people is it's it's a little
anti-democratic in terms of
business when um a couple of winner
winners in a space take all of the money
and so i'm not saying that that's
happening yet because there are
competitors in
in plant-based food space um but it
could get there
and so that's one thing that i think
about just long term right
what do you think in other words you're
saying to the extent that the
impossibles and the beyonds and the
perhaps at some point the memphis meets
are gonna basically create like an
oligopoly of well then based meat
animals if it becomes tough
if it becomes bigger and bigger and like
it's not just a million people but it's
like
or you know i don't know how many
plant-based people there are
um but there's uh you know 50 million
people
buying all these products on a regular
basis
uh if it's going to less and less people
then the wealth is going
into fewer pockets so and and that's
kind of how we got into this
current political situation that we're
in now yeah i mean thinking broadly
about that i think that is something to
bear in mind
i mean there is increasingly more and
more competition there were just a
couple of these now there's
lots of these companies that are that
are doing this
and the technology is also rapidly
evolving yeah um
and you know i wouldn't be surprised if
a couple more companies
start to you know make it make their
mark in this space i agree and maybe
there's a way to do it where you're not
just it's not just
it's it's not a factory here in a
factory there maybe there's a way to
expand it and employ people all over you
know yeah i mean one downstream
implication of this is the monocropping
that you see
with the pea and the soy and the wheat
and all of that which you know
also needs to be addressed quinoa did
that too you know it's like
yeah um there's oh it's always
trade-offs right there's no perfect
solution this is now one solution
so you get people who are going to kfc
to maybe be like you know what
today for my kids i'm going to get the
beyond chicken nuggets because
i can't get my kid to eat anything he
eats the chicken nuggets he's got to eat
something
or she and i'm going to get him the
beyond or
her and beyond well that's a good thing
anything's better than chicken mcnuggets
right right and these aren't mixed
nuggets let's see
yeah exactly but let's start moving in
the right direction and when we look at
the the the biggest
offenders of climate change animal
agriculture is up at the top
yeah so to the extent that we're
creating solutions that are
admittedly imperfect that are
reducing our reliance on the cafo system
to produce food for wide swathes of
the population then that's something
that's good i agree
let's do let's do win of the weeks and
then we'll take a break all right
what do you got when of the weeks well
you want to go first well my buddy
getting a netflix tv show
and blowing up is huge like his book i
think is number 10 now on amazon super
life
and his instagram went i think he might
have had like 70
000 and i checked this morning and he's
at like almost
two hundred thousand now i mean a week
so it's great
he should be you know he should have he
should have a new york times bestseller
and he should have a million followers
on instagram because he deserves it and
he's the real deal so
that's my win of the week well done
darren and you know what's cool is that
the producer
of that series like the company that's
involved where
uh anthony bourdain they used to do
anthony bourdain's show yeah and it
definitely
you know it's it's a tip of the hat to
that genre
yeah programming no question um my win
of the week is live sports coming back
which is partly why i'm wearing this hat
here
go dodgers go lakers um and
i've been waiting for sports you know
i'm not not every
one of our listeners here are are fans
of the ball sport
but i am basketball fanatic baseball
fanatic
too much oh yeah and uh there is a great
vlog
casey neistat tweeted it out and is a
huge fan of it
um and it's by someone who's looked up
to casey for a long time it's a
rookie from the 76ers named matisse
thaible and he was a four-year player at
the university of washington he's now
rookie
on the 76ers and he brought his camera
uh and his particular lens
to the bubble in orlando where all the
players are
and he's got a youtube style show he
started this channel
like a week ago right and there's like
over half a million subscribers
um and he is rocking it with these
really interesting well done
uh edits of 10 minute videos where
you're really seeing kind of this
surreal moment in professional sports up
close and personal he he does everything
he shows you the testing
he shows you the food he shows you how
they're spending their time he shows you
a little bit of the practice court
i think it's really cool i saw casey
tweeted it out
you know maybe at the very beginning
like right after maybe his first video
and he's like this is my new favorite
youtube channel yeah
and now i watch episode two and three
today um he's got almost a million
views on on these videos he's getting
all this press interest
and it definitely owes a debt
of creative inspiration from casey he's
got some cool casey edits in there and
stuff like that
but what i took away from it i think
they're great like i was fascinated
to see this but you just see the
mundanity of these guys who are stuck
basically
in a average hotel in orlando
with not a lot to do other than go to
practice and get tested
just waiting for something to happen
like they're playing cards and they're
trying to figure out like
how to spend their time during the day
and you think of
nba players living this you know crazy
lifestyle
and you realize like it's almost like
they're like stuck in a dorm somewhere
yeah
basically it's a trip you know because
going in when you see the florida
numbers peaking and you worry about
um people getting sick and you think
about it but like watching this actually
made me feel better about the odds of
them getting through the season oh the
precautions that they're taking are
insane yeah they're taking these crazy
precautions they have a lot of resources
at the disposal
um there's really yes do some people who
work in the bubble
go home at night and could they possibly
get infected yes could that
end up in a player getting infected
theoretically yes but there are so many
barriers in place i feel a lot better of
their
opportunity of getting through it i also
think of like
it is surreal like i can't imagine going
through that for like two or three
months like the 76ers are a team that's
a contender they could be there for the
duration the lakers could be there for
the duration i mean we hope they are
but like um and there's all sorts of
reasons why
they're there they're there for their
own financial interests they're there
for the
greater financial interests of nba
players in general because if they don't
get to certain financial benchmarks then
they're
um the the deal they have with the
owners could go away and they can end up
making less money as a collective in
following seasons
um but at the same time they are there
also to entertain
and um they are taking a lot of
discomfort and risk and
there is something there where there
it's it's a selfless act to go to the
bubble in some ways too
it's not just a selfish act to get paid
it's people who
want to serve the game and are do and
are putting themselves in this very
bizarre situation
and part of it is is a public service so
i think i think
that i took that away from it as well
you know it would be wild
if uh if matisse's youtube videos get
more views than the games
that that's not that's not completely
out of the realm of possibility i mean
certainly some games he's gonna he's
gonna
he's going to yeah yeah he reminds me of
who's the tennis player
uh who's the young tennis player [ __ ]
poss [ __ ] poss had a youtube channel
[ __ ] passes is a top 10 tennis player
you know um
matisse is is a rookie and he's kind of
making his name i mean uh
i love the facetimes he does with his
dad by the way yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and but he's and but you know
cece boss had the same thing he has a he
has a youtube channel that was doing
well but he
as a top 10 player he dropped it because
he has other
you know this is kind of matisse's thing
of able to get through the monotony
right
so he's you know right five hours he's
got nothing to do so he's just editing
these videos for hours
it's amazing all right cool let's take a
break take a quick break and we'll be
back with
listener questions all right
all right we're back so listener
questions what do you got for us
okay cool we're gonna start with uh some
that we got through twitter
and facebook this is from patrick dean
via twitter
really enjoying this format here's a
question with all the incredible online
content out there
all the great videos and articles about
everything from personal development and
outdoor athletes to literary and social
issues how can we best ration our time
thanks
patrick it's a good question
i think i think the important thing to
bear in mind is your ratio of
consumption
to creation there's this illusion
of productivity that occurs um
when we're consuming uplifting content
we think we're actually doing something
because
what we're receiving is uplifting and
it's educational
and it's informative and it makes us
feel like
we're capable of achieving our goals
but the illusion of course is that it
convinces you that you've actually done
something when you haven't
so i think it's really important first
of all that's it's good
i think it's really important to be
mindful of your information diet the
kind of content that you're choosing to
consume
on a daily basis it's a great question
in that regard yeah
and and to the extent that we're in this
you know
stay-at-home moment for a lot of us
we're spending much more time in front
of our screens
and it's easy to just click and click
and click and
and mindlessly just hit the next youtube
you know video without thinking through
is this the best allocation of my time
oh it hits it for you
oh it does yeah oh yeah it'll just play
yeah unless you do anything
interrupt the flow exactly just relax in
the barca lounger
so yeah so you gotta you gotta first be
mindful about that diet
your information diet your entertainment
diet and make sure
that you're calibrating it so that it's
in your best interest
then you have to check the valence of
consumption versus creation
there's a lot of talk about screen time
but
i think screen time is too broad a term
because you can be using screen time
to write a book or like matisse edit a
video
or you know write a poem like there's
create music there's there's plenty of
creative productive
positive ways to use screen time where
you're actually
in the creation process rather than the
consumptive process so the first thing
is
doing an inventory of how much of your
screen time is consumptive versus
creative
and trying to calibrate that valence so
that you're using your screen time for
more creative output and then
being objectively honest with yourself
about the extent to which
you're consuming content and perhaps
diluting yourself into thinking that
that's actually um moving you towards
your goals
i guess is the best way of answering
that question i like that do you digest
or do you
produce and if you're not leveraging the
content that you're consuming
to produce or make changes or create
forward motion in your own life
then it becomes a distraction garyvee
says this all the time he's like
i hope that you stop listening to me and
watching me one day because
if you're stuck on just watching those
people who are motivating you but you're
not acting like if you just watch david
goggins videos all day long
but you never put the running shoes on
and go outside or do a single push-up
then you're missing the whole point of
what he's trying to
explain to you yeah right agreed i like
that the ratio of consumption versus
creation
for me i think of screen time and i
don't i don't even think about my
computer it's it's rare that
like i'm on the computer unless i'm
writing or working um i think on my
phone and when i'm on my phone
the screen time really is a consumptive
experience it's not so much a creative
experience although i do take notes in
my phone sometimes so it can
it can blur the line what about all
those tick tock dance moves
you got going on bro don't don't tell
them about my tick tock name
do not do not mention my tick tock
handle
um so in terms of consumption
are there like two or three kind of
go-to things that you're always hitting
like is there is there like a guilty
pleasure or is there something that
you're always like is there a podcast
that you
kind of listen to on a regular basis uh
beyond just kind of just something for
you not really even
for work i mean i would say podcasts are
are the thing that i consume the most on
on my phone
uh and i've been consuming a little bit
less because i'm not in my car as much
but when i'm out training it's
definitely you know that's my go-to
form of edutainment and i mix it up
i mean i have to look at my phone to
tell you what i'm listening to lately
but it tends to be yeah sometimes i'll
use it i i listen to stuff that has
nothing to do with anything that we talk
about here
like if i you know i'm not listening to
the shows that are similar to
my own because that feels like homework
right and i need to
you know broaden my perspective in other
areas so i listen to like a lot of tech
stuff i like
kara swisher and scott galloway and
their pivot podcast
i like i like professor galloway's new
profg show
i've been listening to that i like reply
all which is stories about the internet
wow cool they're fascinating
like long-form kind of journalistic deep
dives into weird corners of the internet
i think that uh those guys pj and uh
alex who hosts that show do an amazing
job you know i like storytelling
yeah i'll listen to some rogan podcasts
but not all of them you know i i mix it
up
gladwell yeah gladwell for sure yeah who
is
i'll say it right now nobody does an ad
read
like malcolm gladwell he throws his
whole body into it that's a full body
experience i want to watch there's a
whole
production that goes into how he crafts
these ad reads and the writing
that that it's funny well you get it
it's where he gets to be funny i think
more than anything and right and he is
funny
um but yeah i was listening to revisions
history the last couple of days it's
good news season is out
big fan it is he's another guy i'm
trying to get on the show we've had
emails back and forth
and haven't been able to make scheduling
happen and that's one i really want to
do in person so
i'm willing to wait a little bit longer
i like it um yeah that's another great
one
okay from bellroomy on facebook
i feel overwhelmingly disheartened by
humanity
i'm generally a happy person and laugh
all the time and still do
but i find myself wanting to get
evangelical about stuff i feel
passionately about
but when i do understandably i feel like
no one wants to hear it
what can i do to abate these feelings of
powerlessness and fatalism
about the future of humanity and the
planet
a little light question for you yeah
right i feel you bellrooming oh yeah we
are um
i'm empathetic to the melancholy yeah i
understand
what that feels like um it reminds me of
of something i tweeted a long time ago
that seemed to connect with people which
was something along the lines of
if you're breaking paradigms you can't
you can't really expect people to
applaud you for it like the mainstream
is not going to take kindly to your you
know
counter programming it just doesn't work
that way right so
if you're trying to do something
different if you're stepping outside of
what is considered to be standard
operating procedure
people tend to be threatened by that and
they're defensive around it and they're
not necessarily going to
celebrate you or accept you for that
choice
and that's just part of it it's not
personal right so the first thing i
think is
understanding that this is not an attack
on you personally
and people who don't want to hear it
from you
are really saying more about themselves
than they are about any choice that
you're making
and i'm also reminded about the life of
john lewis like this is a guy who
basically has been spent he devoted his
entire life to butting up against the
system
to express what he believed in knowing
that he was only going to move the
needle a little bit but it didn't matter
to him because this was his truth right
so
if it's your truth it shouldn't matter
and i think you need to just be clear on
what your values are
and focus on leading the life that you
want to lead
and step outside of any expectation or
desire or need for anybody else to
approve of that
and certainly uh from you know free
yourself from the need to convince
anybody that you're right in there and
you're wrong because that's
a recipe for the fatalism that you're
currently experiencing it's like to be
the change versus
trying to to get people to change right
nothing wrong with activism
i'm a big i mean we need activists but
sometimes there's a limit to what you
can do in terms of person to person
right yeah so live your life
live your truth feel free to express
that
but create a healthy boundary between
yourself
and any expectations you have that
you're going to be convincing anyone
else to
do anything differently than they're
already doing and i think it's important
to
to uh to always lead with compassion and
love and understanding and that's
another thing that john lewis
stood for right he's not coming from
a place of anger and frustration and
judgment
no that never works for anybody so to
the extent that your advocacy or what
you're trying to
express to other people about your
choices versus their choices
to the extent that that is tainted with
some level of judgment or
sense of superiority uh that's
not gonna work right no no one wants to
hear it for a reason because nobody
wants to be told
that they're doing it wrong or no one
wants and people don't want to be judged
so
you have to just live your life live
your truth and
the sense of powerlessness or fatalism
emanates from this attachment that you
have
to other people changing right control
the controllables
all you can control is your behavior
what you're doing
and your reaction to the world and to
the extent that you can be more
mindful and more present and more
responsive and less
reactive the happier you're gonna you're
gonna be as gruesing always says
less emotion more devotion didn't we say
that the other yeah the other day on the
podcast
yeah i'm always thinking about that
right that's great more devotion less
emotion
yeah and um and all i can say is if you
think people don't want to hear about
biodiversity try telling them a swim
story sometimes
they won't bother you ever again about a
swim run race
see how that goes try to give him the
blow-by-bit that's what you're gonna do
you're gonna put a wetsuit on and you're
gonna run down the street
you're gonna love it uh all right
now we're going to the voicemail we're
digging into the voicemail
so let's should we repeat the voicemail
number for people
so that they can do yeah maybe blake can
put that up on the screen too so
we love this new voicemail adam set it
up four two four two three five four six
two six one more time i have to go back
up here four two four
two three five four six two six
awesome let's hear from joe let's hear
from joe from pittsburgh
hi rich and adam joe from pittsburgh
even with the question of schools
reopening unresolved
many parents have already made the
decision to homeschool or use cyber
school this fall
myself included any thoughts or tricks
on how to maintain
sanity while both working and being a
part-time teacher during this
time in history thanks guys and feel
free to use this clip on the air
so also that was echoed by bill lawrence
on facebook who was asking for advice on
resources for home schoolers because he
knew that you and julie
did that at one point yeah yeah so
thanks bill and joe for that question
it's it's kind of a two-part question
one is homeschooling resources and the
other
is how to kind of maintain sanity as a
parent
when you're trying to work and also
homeschool kids
it's tough you know i don't know that i
have the the ultimate answer to that
you do but as somebody here you can lock
yourself in the container i have a
shipping container and i
lock myself in it like a womb and i say
don't bother me
seems to work pretty well um at the same
time julie and i
have spent some time homeschooling our
kids and we both have worked
from home for quite a while so we have
some experience in this so
the first thing is is maintaining your
sanity and i think
um now that everybody is or a lot of
people are working from home now and
that's a new thing
i think it's important to have
boundaries around what is work time and
what is
homeschooling time or or leisure time
right because when you're working from
home it can all bleed into
they all bleed into each other and then
you're kind of always working and never
really working
and and a lot of times you're not 100
present in whatever you're doing because
these things are overlapping so
rule number one is establish your work
hours
and during those times that's when
you're focused on
your profession right and
that also requires you to
you know communicate adequately with
everybody in your family your kids and
your partner or whatever so that
everybody understands
these are the hours when you're doing
this thing and here are the hours we're
going to be doing these other things
and also i think it's important to
still create um
uh a little bit of structure around this
beyond just the scheduling like don't
just sit in your pajamas all day like
you know it's easy to fall into a kind
of depressive melancholy when you're at
home all the time
and just getting dressed like you would
for a normal work day or just
maintaining some of those practices
i think are important in maintaining
your sanity as well
in terms of homeschooling um resources
look education is shifting as professor
galloway will tell you
uh coronavirus is an accelerant
on online learning right like a lot of
the
traditional structures around education
i don't think are gonna come back i
think
there's gonna we're gonna see a lot of
mid-tier colleges go out of business
i think we're gonna see this push
towards more and more online learning
and we're going to see a maturation of
the technological platforms that are
conducive to that
and people are starting to realize that
a lot of the cost that goes into
education
isn't really paying dividends like are
you really going to pay
you know eighty thousand dollars a year
to send your kid to usc
when it's basically zoom calls like
right that's gonna
you know that's gonna really uh upend
the paradigm here so this is being
exacerbated and accelerated by
coronavirus and we're not going to
just pivot back to the normal that we
knew before
like these changes are only going to
accelerate so
what i'm saying by that is that online
learning is going to become more the
norm than the abnormality
that doesn't mean that kids aren't going
to eventually go back to the classroom
they will of course at some point i
don't think it's going to be this fall
for very many people so we're in this
for the long haul
in terms of homeschooling resources i
mean julie and i
are our paradigm with our kids when they
were younger was very much an
unschooling
methodology so it wasn't a lot of
you know kumon and all kinds of online
learning courses
we have tutors we and we we still do for
for jaya who's homeschooled we have a
couple tutors
that she spends time with every week and
works on projects
and and she has some online um
stuff that she does through those tutors
but i don't have
like a list of you know these are the
websites that you go to
does giant been homeschooled this whole
time she has been
okay well she was at a school she was at
muse for a while and now she's been
homeschooled now for
like the last two years oh wow mathis
goes to
an art high school in downtown but now
that's all on zoom
and it's been very difficult because the
appeal of this art school was all the
studio time and the dark room time and
all the practical
you know art-based education that she
was receiving there that was her
lifeblood and now it's just
zoom from you know 8 30 in the morning
to four o'clock at night and it's making
her insane and i don't blame her
you know kids are not wired for that so
to the extent that we're trying to mimic
that classroom experience
by dent of a screen i think is a mistake
i think what we need to do
is leverage the unique opportunities
that are available to us to do something
a little bit more creative and unique
with with our children's education
um one of the things that i think is one
of the opportunities i think we have
is to create a more experiential based
learning experience for kids where
we look at what their this is particular
especially to younger kids like look at
what they're
naturally interested in like what are
they inclined towards when they're not
being told
they have to learn something like what
are they what are what are the things
that they're into is it comic books is
it
you know drawing pictures is it you know
making beats on you know garage band
like what do they
do when no one's looking and then try to
figure out
how to create some kind of learning
experience curriculum
that involves that avenue that
involves that discipline right and use
that
to teach everything from math to english
right like if somebody wants to make
beats well there's an opportunity to
teach them math
music is math right create compositions
learn about
musical notes and how they relate to
math and you know
figure out a way to you know translate
the emotional experience of making music
and listening
music into words that can become an
essay like i
i really believe in in moving towards
their natural interests and trying to
figure out
um how to how to platform that
into a greater understanding that
involves
other disciplines it's a
multi-disciplinary approach it requires
a lot of attention and time on behalf of
the parents
but i think that's how you get kids
engaged in learning
by focusing on what they're already
interested in
rather than trying to compel them to be
interested in something
that they're not oh you mean like the
american ethic of freedom
um what do you mean by that you have to
at least an hour a day
i want them to be indoctrinated on how
freedom is so vital
okay um that's important uh no but i
think it's really interesting it reminds
me of an
old outside magazine article that i read
it was like about
unschooling his kids like he he moved
out to the woods
with his wife and his two young kids and
the whole idea was they weren't going to
home school they were going to unschool
yeah and they were just going to live
off the land and do the best they could
there's like a movie about that with you
remember yeah well yeah the captain
fantastic
that's different i mean captain
fantastic he ran a real school right
he did yes those kids were smart like
that movie hannah
yeah it's like survival that was right
it was different
that was like specific type of
homeschooling captain fantastic
meets like the girl with the dragon
tattoo um
but uh i think that's really interesting
not mimicking normal school
what you what you pointed to there
that's liberating for parents because i
think a lot of people want to do that
because they think and it's also that
goes for don't mimic the normal work day
like you like you said you need to be
able to
be okay with working four or five hours
maybe instead of eight and do it in a
really concentrated fashion
and then do the same thing with the
schooling um you know maybe a morning
session an afternoon session and just
like move the
these are all moving parts they don't
have to look the same way that they did
yeah
and there's a lot of fear with that i've
experienced this myself
because i'm a product of a very
traditional education
and i'm a successful product of that
system right
i went to prep school and i went to
fancy colleges and i went to law
school and so when i look at my kids i
think
well they need to have that experience
or you know
i need to make sure that the value that
i experienced is part of their
upbringing
and for me it's been a process of
letting go of a lot of that
because in truth the educational system
is right for a reboot yeah we're dealing
with the legacy of a system that was
created
you know at the dawn of the industrial
age to basically create
productive create a productive workforce
that was capable
and it really hasn't evolved much past
that in any real tangible way now
we have this moment this interruptive
moment
in which we have the opportunity to
really
evaluate the validity of this system
and reimagine and reinvent it and i
think
you know the hurdle for me has always
been well if we're doing this
unschooling method or if we're doing you
know
pursuing this in a in a relatively
untraditional way like are they going to
know how to do math are they going to
have these fears like
well they're not going to learn about
you know like
pick any subject matter right but when i
really thought about it i thought
well education doesn't really appreciate
the value of the technological tools
that are
at our behest now everybody's got a
super computer
in their pocket that has the answer to
every question they ever
want asked and answered so
this modality of read and memorize
seems completely ludicrous in light of
that
yeah and what we need to do is is focus
more on
critical thinking skills life skills
leadership skills like how do we produce
a well-rounded
self-sustaining individual with solid
self-esteem
and leadership skills and the ability to
listen
and the ability to learn and a love of
learning like what you want to do is
create
somebody who will become a lifelong
learner if somebody's enthusiastic about
learning
and you have a phone or a laptop your
education
doesn't have a start point and an end
point this is something you will have
your entire life
so how can we instill that in young
people how can we get them excited about
learning and
again it goes back to what i said at the
outset which is focus on the things that
they're interested in
and demonstrate to them that
no matter what that interest is it's
it's like a seed
that can then blossom or flourish into
learning about many different anything
because it can intersect with all these
other disciples
everything intersects with everything
else right it's one big web i like that
that's really good and
i like um what you said about mid-level
universities because i always knew that
trump university wasn't that university
it was the time it was if if he launched
it now
it would be a huge hit it'll be a huge
hit maybe um
yes uh julie from southern minnesota
let's hear from julie this is a good
question
hi my name is julie from southern
minnesota
my question is what
advice do you have for a person
who's on a fixed income about
40 pounds overweight so nobody ever
guesses me
at my current weight of 180.
um and with a knee that's been giving me
problems because i'm now 51
and arthritis has decided to take up
residence in my knee so any suggestions
um obviously i don't want to be a
elite athlete but i do want to take up
running that is one of my
dreams and wolves and
so i'm just wondering um
she'd give me a cliff notes version
of how i work up to that
otherwise i'm in good health just chubby
with a bad knee
thank you hi julie
thank you for your question that's a
good question a dream of becoming a
runner
i like it and i appreciate and applaud
your
your honesty um first of all i'd say i'm
not a doctor
so i'm not in a position to give you
medical advice with respect to your
arthritis and your knee so i don't know
exactly what's going on with your knee
and i
i'm reluctant to you know
say anything that's gonna exacerbate
whatever's going on there so the first
thing is
i would go to the doctor and figure out
exactly what's going on there
what you can and you can't do so that
whatever activity you
do um take up isn't going to
make that knee problem worse to the
extent that it's manageable
my best suggestion for you is to
get out and go for a walk these things
start with that right
you're on a fixed income doesn't cost
anything to go out and walk you don't
need to buy fancy shoes you don't need
to buy anything all you need to do is
put one foot in front of the other
and if you ask any of the people that
i've had on the podcast who have gone
from being severely overweight to
becoming
ultra runners people like joshua johnny
it started with a walk around the block
right and you just build very gradually
upon that so that's my only
and best suggestion is to just begin
whatever excuses
you're telling yourself about what you
can and you can't do
are keeping you paralyzed and stuck on
the couch
and it really doesn't have to be
anything that scary or onerous
than that initial walk and then after
you've been doing that
a little bit and you walk a little bit
further and you walk a little bit
farther maybe
try to jog for 10 or 15 yards and see
how that feels
and then the next day you go a little
bit longer and you stay on top of that
knee
and you ice it and you go to the doctor
and you eat
foods that are healing that are
anti-inflammatory that are anti
high in antioxidants and the weight will
start to drop gradually this isn't like
a crash
diet thing or a situation where you're
going to snap your fingers and your
life's going to change overnight
this is a lifestyle shift the idea is
you want to make this shift
that has staying power that helps you
fall in love
with movement that brings joy into your
life by virtue
of exercising your body so that it
becomes an embedded
habit and the easy choice rather than
the hard choice so walk out the door
walk around the block celebrate the
small wins
start to make tweaks small tweaks in
your diet
and as you start to see very gradual
results
you'll experience what we talked about
at the beginning of this podcast
with respect to goals you'll start to
feel more
emotionally attached to this journey
more invested in it
you'll develop that momentum and before
you know it it will become a
self-perpetuating
motion machine that's going to take you
on an amazing journey
i like it and physical therapy can also
help with a knee sometimes and to get
advice from a physical therapist
um would be something i'd recommend help
me without a really bad
foot for a long long time and if you so
if you haven't explored physical therapy
you can usually get that even on a fixed
income you can usually get that
um with uh your health coverage
whatever that may be yeah if you're if
you're if your insurance covers that
great
beyond the physical therapy and and
going to the doctor about your knee
the grand total cost of this experiment
is zero dollars right i love it um
and i remember when i was first getting
back into running after being
on the shelf with that foot problem for
a year
uh started with five minutes running
five-minute walks
you know you wrote like a fartlek type
thing but not at a high intensity
is that something you recommend to yeah
yeah yeah i'm a big believer in that
yeah yeah run walks cool we got one
more for you this one is from
cleveland ohio from ali hi rich and adam
my name is ally i'm from cleveland ohio
and it's certainly okay for you to put
this on the air my question for you
is what your relationship is to
money and i know that you briefly
touched on this in the last episode but
i graduated college a little over a year
ago and i actually decided to pursue a
career in finance because i know that it
can be
a lucrative i have student loans to pay
off in goals of my own
but b i understand that it's really
important for people to have a solid
financial plan
backing them so that they can actually
reach their goals but
at one point at what point is it too
much to be saving
you know too much for retirement or
caring too much about
what you have in the banks you can do
things in the future
and you know choosing to live your life
now because
i feel like i'm very very frugal right
now with the hope that
in the next few years i can do more of
what i want to do but
it certainly takes away from the sort of
purpose i want to have in my life right
now because
i'm so focused on saving and acquiring
money
for the future thanks for tuning in love
you guys
thanks for your question you sound like
a very responsible person
totally much more responsible than i was
she would have had nothing to do with me
when i was 20.
yeah it's a great question
i think that uh it's important
to be fiscally responsible as a young
person then to
to develop healthy habits around
money um at a young age
uh and a healthy respect for what it can
and can't do
i respect that she paid her way through
college yeah it's incredible right
anybody who does that
like celebrate that person
right there and i think it's perfectly
acceptable and laudable to pursue
a career path that will provide you with
financial stability
like i suspect if she paid for her own
college
that she might be coming from a
background in which
it wasn't as financially stable as she
would have liked and and people who
who come from that background are going
to be the people who are more likely to
pursue
a conventional career path that's going
to provide them with the financial
stability that they
lacked i'm just i'm just projecting but
it sounds like that might be the case
here
yeah 100 understandable that she would
want that and need that because that
if that's the case that was lacking
beforehand yeah i think
what she's getting at and what's
important to reckon with here
is this idea well i'm going to get i'm
going to create financial stability for
myself
and i'm going to defer those things that
i really want to do
for the sake of creating that foundation
the idea behind that is
is perfectly fine like i said but the
fear is that
you never get to the purpose part right
because what happens and i've seen this
a million times
i saw it in law school with people who
were like i'm going to go into you know
i'm going to go work the people a lot of
people go to law school because
they want to help humans in certain ways
like in a non-profit context but then
you accumulate all this debt
right and these law firms come along and
they're dangling
six-figure starting salaries and and
people say
well i'm just going to go do the
corporate law thing for a couple years
pay off my debt and then i'm going to go
do the thing
and what happens more often than not is
you
you acclimate to that salary and you
start to create a lifestyle
that only that salary will afford and
there's a keeping up with the joneses
thing that starts to occur
and before you know it you're leasing a
car that you can't quite afford and
you're in a mortgage
and all these things then make you stuck
in a career path and it makes it more
and more difficult to then
shift gears and pursue that passion
yeah purposeful life that you had
aspirations for as a young person
so the good news is you're super young
your whole life is ahead of you
pursue that career path in finance
create that
foundation of financial stability but i
would
strongly suggest not that you're not
doing this already but
that you live as minimally as possible
and refrain from any of those
expenses that later on can prevent you
from
being nimble with your career you know
it sounds like you're good at saving
money which is fantastic
and also to remember that it's important
to
to invest in experience right if you
keep your overhead low
you create choices for yourself and
flexibility with your career path and
you have the ability to
invest in experiences whether those are
trips or
learning things that you want to learn
in your life career
other hobbies things like that as long
as you can do that
then you then have the freedom to make
those changes later
later on in life that's really great
advice um
the only thing i'd add to that i didn't
do any of those things as a young person
me i didn't know you didn't no well you
were a
dashing swimmer at stanford no but i
made a lot of mistakes i wish i could
change so my
my message to young people is always
like live lean right
you know and and and try to protect that
ability to be flexible and nimble i
think that's right and
i i think that's great advice and it
seems like she's on that path doesn't
seem like she's acquiring a whole lot at
this point
right um but i would say that this this
cra this craving for purpose is real and
fomo is real
and sometimes we're so attached back to
the consumption but
so attached to our phones and we see
people living lives of so-called purpose
or
having these experiences that are like
you know bucket list type experiences
and
and and she's like grinding it out
saving money
um first of all a lot of that is is
false it's not as
great and or ideal as it looks like so
don't don't
you know you got to make sure to check
yourself i'm not saying that she is
indulging in
or or subject to fomo we all are at some
level
um but the other thing i would say is
purpose doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be sensible career or
purpose
it can be both and and your purpose
doesn't have to be your sensible career
and
in in the interim i think purpose is
going to be
really important for you to be able to
get through kind of grinding
weeks that are harder to get through and
one way of doing that is volunteering or
finding some way to connect
with something that you do care about so
i i would say that there
there are ways to mitigate that in the
interim before you kind of make that
nimble
jump to i think that's a really
important point
and and we think of like purpose
in this binary context like you're
either in this
financially secure career or you're
living this purpose-driven you know
right
it doesn't have to be that way and it's
not that way um
you can find purpose in in any in
anything that you're doing in any
pursuit and
if you feel you know bereft of that in
your particular career choice
you can find purpose in just trying to
be of maximum service to
the people that you report to right or
just doing the best job that you can
absolutely you can like zen in on the
the actions you're taking at work
you can you know volunteer as a literacy
coach or something like that or or help
people with finances that might need
help or
uh people in trouble with their
mortgages whatever it might be
yeah and uh but yeah uh thanks for the
question it's a good one
cool that's what we have man we did it
we wrapped it how do you feel i feel
good i like that
we're shaping this thing into something
uh well i told you at the outset
yeah we could create a structure for it
but ultimately it's going to tell us
what it wants to be and i think we're
slowly finding that
yeah but i think we're hitting a good
stride with this
yeah and uh it's always good to be here
man thanks for having me of course man
my pleasure we'll be back in another two
weeks uh in the meantime you can follow
adam at adam skullneck i'm easy to find
at richroll everywhere
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button on youtube apple or spotify
as always you can find links to
everything we discussed today in the
show notes on the episode page on my
website at richroll.com
you can submit your questions on the
facebook group or on the
voicemail 424-235-4626 at some point
i'll uh
i'll memorize that yeah and tell me that
you
you know how you feel about wearing a no
don't no but wear a mask
and don't tell me anything about your
feelings about it but just wear it right
um all right thanks you guys i
appreciate you i don't take your
attention for granted it means a lot
that you've
spent this time uh with me and without
him every yeah thank you guys so
appreciate it what do you want to sign
off with
don't you do yourself put you on the
spot me yeah
be cool be kind there you go peace
plants namaste
[Music]
you